look what they've sent us and look what
that tells us about our opponents so
what do they tell you basically an email
he's sending me that the topics of
discussion yeah is um first of all
[Music]
um
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
so it's just gone past midnight and we
have come to do this video and we're
going to tell you why I want to give you
guys maybe an analogy imagine you are
being offered a fight khabib and Andrew
Tate you guys are Fighters imagine your
opponent tells you that you are going to
fight them but your hands have to be
tied behind their back and the sponsors
and organizers of this event are all a
part of this so is a referee at one
moment of time you're going to be asking
a question
is why do you require me to have my
hands tied behind my back while you have
gloves on
and this tells you or tells us more
about our opponents and the organizers
and even the referee it says a lot about
them now this is in the sense of a
fight but this is an intellectual battle
here yeah so brothers and sisters value
treatment Patrick Pat David is that his
name
yeah but okay okay so
I don't really know for that matter you
have seen some of his videos
um I've seen some of your videos which
you um you know correct them on some
matters and I had my perceptions about
him and I thought maybe I'm maybe
jumping the gun let's give him a chance
Etc because recently he has been trying
to kind of Outreach to khabib and yes so
we thought you know what Muslim people
exactly so we thought okay I've been
good with them exactly so here is what
happened guys when it comes to the title
of the video which is we were about to
be ambushed but we ambushed the Ambush
how because we was invited myself
individually I've got an email you got
an email from valuetainment and we were
speaking to an individual called Robert
and this these negotiations have been
taking place so I'll say overall two
months now yes there was first
initiation that they sent an email yeah
then they went silent no problem because
I'll be honest with you I'm not really
fussed about going there I'll be very
very honest and blunt it's it's the
least of my concern
um so we got this email the first email
was what hijab what was the first thing
that they sent you it was an invitation
I do actually want to kind of read it
out because I don't wanna I don't want
to um misrepresent it right so okay so
you open it inshallah so this is we
initially got a couple of months ago a
message then they went silent then they
messaged us about a couple of weeks
before that and they said that they want
to invite me and Mohammed hijab they
want to fly us to fly us out to Florida
and here is what they said the
discussion is going to be about yeah so
in the beginning it said look Patrick
would like to do a round table
discussion on religion specifically
Islam Christianity Islam that is
establishing a Masjid and a community
center if you don't need to build this
Masjid Allah build the house for you in
Jannah with bricks of gold and silver
every person who prays in this Masjid
every child that memorized the Quran you
will inshallah share in that reward
don't it now guys and do not delay
foreign